MARK MIRCHANDANI: Ugh, I
have all these teammates
asking me to spit out
new projects for them.
But each one requires
special tweaks,
and then I have to apply
the standard configuration.
ADAM OCSVARI: That's it?
Just use the Cloud Deployment
Manager to create projects.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh,
that's the infrastructure
and configuration
as code tool, right?
Isn't that kind
of hard to set up?
ADAM OCSVARI: No, not at all,
if you use the Cloud Foundation
Toolkit template, such
as the Project Factory.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Can we see how it works?
ADAM OCSVARI: Sure thing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Cloud Foundation Toolkit
has a lot of great templates
to get started from.
Let's begin with some easy
firewall rules, as a warm up.
Looking up a template
at the CFT repository,
you will find a readme,
how to use the template,
with a ready-to-go
example configuration.
First, let's go in the repo and
jump into the templates folder.
Now, copy the
example file and fill
out the mandatory properties
about your environment--
in this case, the VPC name,
which is the network where
you want the firewalls to live.
For now, let's use
the default network.
Make sure you enable the
required APIs, Compute
and Deployment
Manager, and then we
are ready to launch
the deployment.
Using the GCloud
CLI, our resources
will be created via
Deployment Manager,
within a couple of seconds.
This shows up in the
Cloud console immediately.
If we go back to the config
and change some properties,
we can update the resources
during its lifecycle,
via Deployment Manager.
If we refresh the
list of firewalls,
we can see the changes.
Finally, by deleting
the deployment,
we clean up all the
resources which we created.
Now comes the real deal.
We create a shared
VPC host project,
adding subnetworks in it.
Then we create a guest
project and attaching it
to one of those subnets.
First, let's set our
environment variables
and enable the required APIs,
based on prerequisite section
of the readme.
Don't forget to allow Deployment
Manager to attach your billing
account to projects.
After copying and
filling out the example,
open the configuration
file and edit at the end.
Because, first, we create
the VPC host project.
Now, let's launch
the deployment.
It usually takes a
couple of minutes
to create all of
these resources.
Now, we copy the network
template example and launch it
with all the default settings
in the VPC host project,
which we just created.
Last step is to copy the project
example configuration again,
for the guest project.
Fill out the
environment properties,
and make sure we are referencing
the recently created subnet
we wish to attach
this project to.
After the same
create comment, we
can see, at the Cloud
console, the two projects--
the network with the
subnets at the host project
and the attached guest project.
There you go.
You just implemented the
automated project factory
in your organization.
Check out our GitHub repository,
the Deployment Manager
best practices, and some
further bedside stories,
down at the description.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And don't forget
to subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]